There is sort of a golden rule
when it comes to founding,
co-founding, partner founding companies.
One, obviously is easy because all
decisions rest with one person.
Two, is good and
powerful because it's a conversation.
Three, is probably the limit.
I don't know that I would ever get
involved in a business where there was
more than three top partners
who are making decisions.
The reason for that is,
three people form a very strong axis.
You have lots of strengths
on the table and
all the weaknesses
typically are covered.
And you won't ever have
one person dominating,
if you do then it's actually a sole
proprietor with two lackeys.
So we won't get into that but
a three co-founder business I found,
in my experience to be very strong.
One of the businesses I was part of,
I was one of three co-founders and
we were very powerful in what were doing
because we each brought a different
skill set to the table, and a different
temperament given changing environments
and scenarios that were playing out.
So, as those things played
out we each stepped up
in the given situation with
our skills and overcame them.